watch out old Joe a Kennedy wants back
in the White House
my mission over the next 18 months of
this campaign and over my throughout my
presidency
will be to end the corrupt merger of
state and corporate power is threatening
now to impose a new kind of corporate
feudalism in our country well Joe Biden
drags his feet on a 2024 run Robert F
Kennedy Jr is ready to challenge him for
the Democratic nomination the media is
trying to write RFK Jr off as a fringe
candidate but he's already snagging 14
of Joe's voters that's no fringe and 32
percent of Dems would rather have
anybody but Biden the president could
stop all the Democrat backstabbing if he
was popular and had a strong record to
run on but the White House can't even
defend that
69 of people pulled by CNBC say they
have a negative view of the economy
and talks about the economy all the time
what it talks about people lying he
talks about the economy all the time
because he wants the American people to
know that he's doing everything that he
can to make sure that he's that his
policies that he's put forward that has
shown that he's building an economy that
doesn't leave anybody behind I know
you're reading a poll right now that is
one poll
there you go it's just one pull so Dana
uh it's an RFK offers an interesting
intersection of stances which makes his
impact kind of hard to predict like who
does he hurt more Republicans Or
democrats obviously he's certainly
buying right now but he's an old school
liberal anti-war distrustful of
government you know uh uh but then what
used to be hard left which was anti-vaxx
is kind of now across all politics but
it can be part right A lot of these
things where people on the right and the
left have met around on the other side
and I just sit there and go like I don't
I I'm not there yeah but I've watched it
happen and it's on several issues many
issues including some of the labor union
stuff so a lot of Democrats rolling
their eyes right they're saying oh gosh
so here we go again but the 14 is one of
the things his name has the cachet not
as much as it used to yeah but Camelot
has kind of left the building on that
one but look at where he did the event
he had a very good roll out he did it in
Boston
Boston's media market shares with
New Hampshire
Biden has really given the middle finger
to New Hampshire by saying that we're
going to do the first of the primaries
in South Carolina instead New Hampshire
voters are even if they're partisan
Democrats they're not happy about that
and so you might see if there's a way
that RFK Jr would be able to push Biden
into having to debate now you haven't
seen the White House actually get
concerned and we know what can happen
and we'll talk about it in the show
about when the White House campaign
Biden's campaign gets going they could
even get you know a couple of dozen
National Security advisors to say things
that aren't true so what kind of
opposition research could they do on
something like this if they put their
mind to it they might not think that
they want to do it but Joe Biden is a
historically weak incumbent so it is it
is interesting it's also probably very
unlikely that he would go much further
than even the 14 but I'm willing to sit
here and watch because I'm all 20 24 an
observer yeah you know I'm calling
myself Geraldo you saw RFK Jr on Tucker
I mean it's it's so interesting to see
how different Worlds Collide from like
you know you never thought you would
happen but this is how the world's
changing how is the Kennedy name does it
have do you think it has an effect
you've been on in this on this planet
for quite a long time right I've known
them all Doug uh Kennedy his brother is
my was for many years my office mate uh
I think that he's going to be much more
formidable than you Vindicated not you
but I mean people are taking him uh with
a grain of salt but I he's got the
accent he's got the Nostalgia he's got
the looks uh the anti-vaxx thing is less
crazy now than it was a year or two ago
so I I would submit that uh I mean he's
not Gavin Newsom who's still my favorite
of that generation I still think it's
going to be Trump against Biden uh but I
think that Joe Kennedy uh junior I mean
Robert Kennedy Junior excuse me there's
so many uh Robert Kennedy Jr is going to
be a a formidable force a disrupter that
the very least what do you say judge
disrupter
um I worked with Robert Kennedy Jr when
I was the D.A I had an environmental
crimes unit I was very forward very
Progressive in that regard I found him
to be a uh a very ethical guy who really
believed in what he was doing uh he
wasn't cheap about politics he wasn't an
easy Mark he was someone who believed in
what he believed and I think it'll be
very interesting to watch him
um I I think when you put someone up
like him against Joe Biden and we see
he's taken 35 percent of the Democrats
who don't like Joe Biden who think he's
too liberal and 33 percent who of Joe
Biden's people who who think that the
economy is terrible I think he has an
opportunity if he's given that
opportunity he is almost like
um and it's curious Dana the way you
described it coming around in the back
you know the left and the right kind of
meeting back there somewhere I think
that people will find in him if there's
enough of a chance I know his family is
trashing him his family the Kennedy
family is trashing him they're so left
so Progressive they don't want to deal
with him but I think that some Americans
will find him to be kind of reminiscent
of better times in America and I think
it'll be I think it'll be very
interesting to watch uh he's not about
corporate greed he's not about running
around the world and sucking up money
with a vacuum cleaner you know for the
family
he might be uh uh I don't know he I had
issues with him for going back probably
20 20 some odd years just because I
worked in the health journalism area and
and the anti-vaxx movement was one of
the most strident ideologically like
hardcore but he turns out that now he's
known for this stance the covet stance
so it's I I don't I wouldn't say it's a
stop clock and that he was finally right
but what do you make of that now that I
mean it's weird how his he's now become
kind of a uh I mean a folk hero of
people who aren't typically liberals so
what you're saying is all those years of
being anti-vaxx might have been
Vindicated most recent vaccine even news
this week yeah um I I don't know if
those other vaccines pose anywhere near
the threat that he believes and puts out
there but I kind of I don't think that
the left and right Mead in the middle
around the back of the political sphere
I think that a lot of Americans sit here
in the middle and when they are not on a
team that's you know Kevin McCarthy's
team or Joe Biden's team then they're
just focused on things that affect their
lives when you talk about Farmers that
want to be able to raise a farm without
Monsanto owning them when you talk about
people that want to raise their kids
without teachers indoctrinating them
when you talk about people that want to
I don't know not pay all their money in
taxes or as we'll talk about later pay
more because they have good credit
that's really not political ideology
that's middle class or low-class people
trying to live their lives and if you
can show up and actually do something
for those people rather than being
someone like Joe Biden or many
Republicans who make a platform out of
pretending to do something for those
people you're going to get 10 or 14 but
what I want to know is if these obscure
candidates are doing that good against
Biden who are the real contenders and I
don't mean to say he isn't but who are
the ones that are looked at as real
contenders they're chomping at the bit
to jump in maybe there aren't any
because maybe all those have already
sold or sold to the far left I don't
know it's a good way to look at it and I
just want to say like in my ear while we
were talking here a news has just
crossed we have not confirmed it yet at
Fox News but like I think the New York
Times is reporting that that apparently
Joe Biden will announce he's running for
re-election next Tuesday in a video
[Music]
uh that will be April 25th all right in
case you're counting so that news just
came across you know what a shock you
know the guy's doing it in the video I
mean it didn't come out right and it
comes right as they are gathering the
Biden fundraisers are coming this week
or this weekend yeah so they probably
had to figure out a way to he probably
already cut the video on a good day oh
yeah maybe the job's not that hard after
all you know are you up for it no I'm
gonna wait till 2028 can we put your
name watch out America me I wanna Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now